ou vous c'est nous les tuons
des frites et une coupe mulet bien
caractéristique pour j'ai pu jouer
cette coupe mulet fait partie de la
panoplie du personnage qui retrouve une
quatrième fois le public des salles
obscures une coiffure ou plutôt osons le
dire une légende capillaire apparu dans
les années 80 et le centre est
[Musique]
ce sont d'abord les femmes plus des
merrer sûrement qui se lancent dans
l'aventuré mulet mais attention reste en
place on ne parle pas de nuque longue
mais denuc profonde nuance pour celles
qui sont réfractaires aux cheveux courts
la haute coiffure a prévu une version
plus longue volumes importants toujours
sur le dessus de la tête mais l'ugtt
profondes excuses cette coupe va aussi
séduire les hommes et en premier les
footballeurs comme chris waddle remarqué
ce mulet parfaitement bouclé milieu des
années 80 sportifs ou pas c'est la coupe
à avoir c'est la télé qui le dit quant à
vous messieurs résolument vous aurez les
chevaux plus long il faut vous y faire
si vous n'avez pas les biceps et les au
moins de la chevelure et la coupler va
faire des émules toutes les stars des
années 80 la porte chuck norris mel
gibson ou même jane fonda version us en
france le mulet est aussi dans le vent
regarder balavoine et goldman
[Musique]
ou encore francis cabrel même si on sent
un petit ton moqueur de la part de cette
journaliste très parisienne lui il fait
sa carrière sans bruit et se contrefiche
de son look préférant s'afficher comme
un vrai provincial doit sans cesse se
ressourcer dans son sud ouest natal il a
la coupe mulet et s'en fiche de son look
et si c'était ça au fond la philosophie
mulet la coupe de la liberté la coupe de
l'audace depuis quelques années elle
revient en force et ses adeptes la
défendent comme une nouvelle façon de
vivre vous pouvez m'expliquer c'est quoi
le secret pour une coupe mulet parfaite
alors déjà le truc le plus important
c'est que le client soit d'accord sur
toutes les personnes aient envie de le
porter parce que c'est quand même
quelque chose de très particulier qui
qui attire autant le regard que le
tatouage il ya dix ans des mots des
beaufs la coupe mulet a aujourd'hui ces
championnats ses adeptes les années 80
sur la tête
[Musique]